[Musique]
disons qu'ils appellent le plus ces deux
sentiments rares à la fois le respect et
l'affection avec ce que en mode affiche
il ya de relation secrète et personnel
on aime jaurès jaurès était
fondamentalement une nature unitaire ils
voulaient l'unité partout ils la
voyaient dans la nature entre la nature
et l'esprit la voyaient entre les hommes
c'est un homme qui se bat pour que
l'humanité soit plus humaines
jean jaurès a été un moment de la
conscience humaine dans les havres
combat qu'il a connu politique le monde
bouleversement des combats sociaux une
hauteur de vue en même temps une
capacité à s'élever au dessus de
l'immédiat le change de ce qu'a pensé
jaurès de ce qu'il a interrogées est
encore devant nous et les effets de
cette redécouverte ou à mon avis vous
comptez dans les décennies qui viennent
sur une multitude de questions en débat
aujourd'hui guerre la paix la laïcité
la question de la propriété les moyens
du changement à j entends lieu pense
avec le monde sans que toute sa vie
c'est ce qu'il a essayé de faire
[Musique]
en
le vrai héritage de jaurès c'est nous
qui n'avons aujourd'hui aux mains du
temps après la mort de jean jaurès
personne ne paraît plus hésiter
aujourd'hui à saluer sa mémoire et le
prendre en référence à gauche bien sûr
puisqu'il en fut un acteur sans pareil
mais à droite aussi jaurès bizet la
nation c'est le seul bien dépôt
la gauche a abandonné la nation
l'extrême droite même s'en est emparé
sans vergogne cet homme de combat et de
conviction est désormais au coeur d'une
sorte d'unanimisme étrange s'y ajoutent
la multitude des avenues des rues des
collèges qui porte son nom les statuts
des timbres poste
et tout cela risque dattiers dire un
homme de feu le figer enceinte du
vitrail de notre république
mais quand savent donc nos contemporains
qui répètent de la sorte indéfiniment
son nom et que peut-il avoir encore à
nous dire son meurtre le 31 juillet 1914
à paris alors et même de la grande
guerre
fut si dramatique
qu'il a contribué à simplifier la
complexité de jean jaurès
parce que l'émotion submergé la
réflexion
pierre renaud des l'un de ses proches
étaient à ses côtés ce jour-là il
raconte
c'est arrivé tard à l'humanité il est
20h allons dinero plus frais au
croissant d une nous y serons davantage
entre nous
[Musique]
m
il ya là avec lui amédée dunois et
relève des marguerites poissons dont je
vais agnel renoue pour ses amis de
partie ses collaborateurs
enfin philippe landrieu et pierre
renaudin en peu d'eux jean jaurès et à
qui le fut en vain la plastique
le taux de vente une fenêtre de la rue
moma il fait chaud
la fenêtre est ouverte un brise bise ces
parcelles jaurès la curiosité de la rue
ou long de cette journée du 31 juillet
jaurès a jeté toutes les fortes sa
conviction de sa parole de son influence
à la chambre des députés au ministère
des affaires étrangères pour contribué à
entraver du côté français la guerre qui
vient en fin d'après-midi à son journal
l'humanité
il a commencé de rédiger un article
qu'il veut un appel ultime à la sagesse
des gouvernements et des peuples
j'aurais préoccuper les supporter en
cours à sa bonne humeur
le voici qui s'intéresse aux peluches et
des monographies en couleurs il est déjà
21h40
toutacoo du classement je regarde jaurès
dont la tête est la lumière de sur mes
genoux
la mort est là dès 22h la nouvelle s'est
répandue comme une traînée de poudre et
la foule se presse devant le lieu du
drame dans la nuit on moule le visage du
défunt pour en faire un masque mortuaire
le café du croissant devient aussitôt un
lieu de pèlerinage on y cherche la
dernière trace de jaurès pour ceux qui
l'ont connu le souvenir en reste
puissant
lesquels tous les jeunes qui avait tout
le monde avec moi il était calme à
braver tout le monde n'était pas lui
même comme tout le monde c'était du
silence
les chiens qui sont en demande doit pas
beaucoup comme lui c'est dans une petite
ville du sud-ouest carmaux dans le tarn
que le deuil et le plus profond car
c'est là que s'est ancrée au coeur du
monde ouvrier
les landes de la formidable énergie
politique de jean jaurès
aujourd'hui encore on peut y voir les
vestiges de ce qui fut à la fin du 19e
siècle un bassin minier important
3000 ouvriers y travaillent dans des
conditions très rudes à l'extraction du
charbon leur mode de vie est marquée par
la violence impitoyable de la révolution
industrielle la protection sociale est
dérisoire
le patronat est brutal parfois cynique
en août 1892 les ouvriers de la mine se
mettent en grève
à l'origine du mouvement licenciement de
jean baptiste calvignac maire de carmaux
et mineur au motif que ses activités
politiques porterait atteinte à son
efficacité de travailleurs le
gouvernement envoie la troupe pour
rétablir l'ordre
les transforme du coup l'événement en
enjeu national jean jaurès universitaire
professeur de philosophie à la faculté
de toulouse ancien député de centre
gauche se jettent dans la bataille aux
côtés des grévistes
il affiche sa solidarité avec les
protestataires
et ils l'expriment chaleureusement jour
après jour
[Musique]
le gouvernement finit par imposer la
réintégration de calvignac dans
l'entreprise
le patro des mines qui est député
démissionne par dépit les mineurs
sollicite la candidature de jean jaurès
qui était lui cette fois sous
l'étiquette socialiste en janvier 1893
socialiste il l'est avec le sceau du
monde ouvrier
définitivement est-ce que vous pensez
que ces grèves peuvent encore nous dire
aujourd'hui dire aux acteurs de des
conflits sociaux à prendre quelque chose
jean esponde reste un repère dans les
conflits présent même alors en quoi dans
leur refus de la violence
ça c'est clair il faut trouver des
solutions et trouver des solutions
c'est pas tout d'un seul coup tout de
suite mais penser que la grève générale
va résoudre les problèmes 8 semble se
tromper de méthode on ne peut pas
changer un pays tout simplement parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de grévistes
c'est là ce qu'ils opposent un jules
guesde notre leader majeur du parti
socialiste pense qu'il va pouvoir
renverser la table et que d'ailleurs le
réformisme et dangereux puisqu'ils
risquent de diminuer l'énergie des
milieux ouvriers pour faire la
révolution
jean sd c'est plutôt de faire comprendre
qu'il vaudrait mieux évoluer en méthodes
qu'ils puissent aboutir réellement à une
révolution à des changements profonds au
socialisme qu'il voulait se saisissent
humaniste ce n'est pas les syndicats
tout seul qui vont pouvoir régler
l'ensemble des problèmes auxquels ils
sont affrontés c'est une république
sociale qui va faire se rejoindre au
verger l'action collective et les
responsables élus pour cela les
parlementaires et donc pour lui il est
sûr que quand il allait de carmaux au
parlement pour exprimer son indignation
il a été jusqu'à mettre à mal le
gouvernement c'est à dire que à l'époque
les conditions sociales était tellement
difficile que cette liaison directe
action sociale action parlementaire
était une grande nouveauté
en 1895 le député jaurès intervient
encore sur les terres de carmaux cette
fois pour appuyer les ouvriers de la
verrerie
les verriers se sont mis en grève à la
suite du licenciement de leur délégué
syndical le patron et réductible à toute
concession réponse à la grève en fermant
le site et en jetant au chômage les 1200
ouvriers l'ardeur de jaurès va permettre
de trouver une solution inattendue
l'idée est venue de faire une verrerie
ouvrière
ça c'est passionnant parce que ça veut
dire que c'est une initiative d'une en
bas une coopérative possible une autre
forme de travail dès qu'il est apparu et
l'a soutenu et dit voici une issue parle
pas d'une issue pour la france entière
mais aussi une issue possible
his les seniors qui correspondrait donc
qu'est ce qu'il fait il va à paris et
voit ses amis bourgeois progressive
bourgeois éclairé et il repose il
rassemble des sommes d'argent
importantes étaient tout heureux jours
il avait une femme à paris pour le
bourgeois 13 cents mille cent mille
francs
ce n'est point par la pesante monotonie
d'une bureaucratie centrale que sera
remplacer le capitalisme mais par des
organes sans nombre comme une
coopérative syndicats qui donneront à la
propriété sociale
le mouvement le plus souple et le plus
libre la verrerie ouvrière est
construite à albi elle est inaugurée par
jean jaurès en 1896 elle fonctionnera
sous cette forme coopérative pendant
près d'un siècle à la veille de sa mort
en 1914 jaurès dit aux ouvriers de
carmaux qui avait entouré son ralliement
au socialisme je ne demande qu'une chose
c'est de rester dignes de vous
c'est cette dimension là qui manque m
ses capacités hauteur de la vérité qui
aujourd'hui s'occupe réellement de
l'avenir de la moitié de la population
qui vote peu qu'ils se mobilisent peu
qui est nationalisé de fait que ce pass
chômage de feu même par le lieu
d'habitation avant d'abidjan reste là
pour robert roberts et à un exemple de
de ce que des femmes et les hommes
peuvent faire pour changer un peu
l'atmosphère et éclairer un peu l'avenir
le lendemain du meurtre de jaurès le
samedi 1er août 1914
toute la presse se fait l'écho du drame
le monde des prolétaires est en deuil un
bref moment le gouvernement redoute que
ses funérailles provoque des
manifestations pacifistes partout à
paris il fait placarder des affiches qui
appelle au calme en dépit du chagrin
collectif cette inquiétude n'est pas
fondée la certitude d'un embrasement
désormais inévitable domine tous les
esprits sur les mêmes murs la
mobilisation générale est annoncée
lorsque les obsèques officielles de
jaurès ont célébré le 4 août au matin
parmi un grand concours de fouler en
présence des autorités de la république
les jeux sont faits les dirigeants
ouvriers socialistes qui viennent
apporter à jaurès
l'hommage de leur douleur et de leur
fidélité annonce d'un même mouvement qui
ne se déroberont pas au devoir
patriotique de la mobilisation
et tandis que les troupes montent au
front son corps est transporté en sens
inverse à albi pour y être ensevelies
dans sa terre natale
ce terme qui l'a vu naître à castres en
là où il faut chez le photographe avec
son frère cadet selon le rituel de la
bourgeoisie provinciale du temps au
début de la troisième république
ce n'était qu'une petite couche de la
population qui avait accès aux études
secondaires et encore mois aux études
supérieures
il y a eu des exceptions c'est ce qu'on
appelle ce qu'on appelait mon la
méritocratie scolaire dont jaurès a
profité après le primaire devient élève
au collège de castres petite ville du
tarn ont il va faire des études
secondaires
si brillante ils raflent tous les prix
les bons dans toutes les disciplines
et voilà qu'un jour il ya un petit
monsieur qui arrive dans une classe
c'est l'inspecteur général et
l'inspecteur général et si émerveillé
par ce garçon que le maître a fait
parler il va lui faire obtenir une
bourse afin de préparer l'école normale
supérieure à paris et il est reçu du
premier coup à l'école normale
supérieure en même temps que henri
bergson du reste moi ce qui me frappe
c'est le côté je dirais presque poétique
de l'ascension de jaurès vous imaginez
bon vie de castres dans le tarn
comment aurait-il pu échapper je dirais
une destinée
modeste comme comme celle de ses parents
et bien voilà il y avait quand même
c'est cet instrument extraordinaire
cette instruction publique avec ses
inspecteurs qui temps en temps arriver à
faire décoller un élève à l'arraché de
l'archet de sa situation je nie par
médiocre mais mes modestes et deux de
pouvoir en faire un des plus grands
hommes de la république
mais alors qu'il semble promis à une
paisible carrière de professeur jaurès
bifurque vers la politique
à 26 ans il obtient son premier mandat à
castres il devient le plus jeune député
de france
jaurès et philosophe docteur ès lettres
mais aussi historien sont formidables
labeur n'a pas reculé devant le projet
d'une vaste histoire socialiste de la
révolution
cette grande révolution qui est la
matrice à ses yeux de toutes les
générosités du siècle écoulé une
histoire qui est aussi une action jaurès
a écrit son histoire socialiste de la
révolution française de 1789 à 2 794 et
il l'a fait véritablement en historien
cela dit son histoire ne ressemble pas
aux histoires de l'université d'abord il
y a l'objectif socialiste pourquoi
socialiste ce qui nous choque n'est ce
pas nous listes rien puisque après tout
une histoire ne doit être ni socialiste
ni républicaine ni vollard schiste elle
doit être de l'histoire point final
c'est que pour lui l'histoire doit être
enseignée de manière pédagogique et
militante aux ouvriers c'est ce qu'ils
visent avant tout il invite ses lecteurs
ouvriers prolétaires à saisir ce qu'il
pouvait y avoir avant la révolution
socialiste de grandeur dans la
révolution bourgeoise ce qu'elle avait
d'universel par exemple les droits de
l'homme et du citoyen ce que disent les
marxistes sont des droits formels un
masque qui rejette n'est ce pas dans
l'ombre les vraies motivations les
intérêts la défense des intérêts de la
bourgeoisie
tout est économique tout est social
voilà ce n'est pas du tout la vie de
jaurès il se démarque de marx en
affirmant qu' il y à un moment où
l'universel qui sera la société future
ou dès à présent représenté porté par le
prolétariat pouvait l'être en 1789 par
la bourgeoisie et qu'il ne faut pas lire
la déclaration des droits de l'homme
comme un leurre qui cache les intérêts
d'une classe sociale mais bel et bien
comme une déclaration humanistes
universelles
[Musique]
entre 1894 et 1906 la société française
est bouleversée par la sphère dreyfus et
jean jaurès
ils jouent un rôle décisif
à l'origine de la sphère la condamnation
du capitaine alfred dreyfus par un
conseil de guerre pour espionnage et sa
déportation en guyane
[Musique]
jaurès est étonné comme d'autres au
début à gauche que le traître et
échapper à la peine capitale
il est allé jusqu'à s'écrier on a
surpris un prodigieux développement de
la puissance juive pour sauver l'un des
siens mais quatre ans plus tard
l'article retentissant d'emile zola
publié dans l'aurore change la donne
l'innocence de dreyfus ne fait plus de
doute pour les esprits lucides qui
examine sereinement le dossier comme le
fait jean jaurès visiblement l'armée
protège par des documents faux son
aveuglement et ses passions anti sémite
jaurès se porte au premier rang du
combat pour que l'erreur judiciaire soit
réparé ce qui à mon sens car cas et
jaurès c'est le refus de la justice ne
supporte pas la justice ça le brûle
alors on le retrouve du côté des paysans
russes des ouvriers allemands et bien
sûr de prolétariat français c'est parce
que à leur égard l'injustice est
impitoyable justice sociale
l'injustice qui frappe dreyfus elle
frappe à bourg voix c'est une injustice
faite à la bourgeoisie un des siens
parce que l'antisémitisme est là à
l'oeuvre
dans une france où les deux camps
dreyfusards et antidreyfusard
s'affrontent avec violence brisant des
solidarités familiales et politique qui
paraissait indestructible je reste
reçoit bien des goûts mais sa conviction
est inflexible
[Musique]
en pleine affaire dreyfus en effet il y
à un débat entre lui et jules guesde
est ce que le prolétariat nous à
s'occuper de l' affaire dreyfus guen dit
non il faut laisser les bourgeois se
débrouiller entre eux ce n'est pas la
faire des ouvriers de s'occuper de la
défense du capitaine dreyfus les autres
choses à faire et ce n'est pas la vie de
jaurès jaurès pense que dreyfus n'est
pas du tout représentants de la
bourgeoisie l'humanité souffrante et
c'est une victime et en tant que victime
il représente l'humanité souffrante
effectivement est victime de l'injustice
et par conséquent en dreyfus on défend
aussi pour l'état ria il publie une
série d'articles dans lesquels ils
démontrent les illégalités commises
depuis 1894 dans l'instruction contre
alfred dreyfus et dans le déroulement du
procès devant un tribunal militaire
ouvrage rassemblant ses articles et
publiée en octobre 1898
c'est une démonstration irréfutables de
l'innocence du condamné
nous pouvons sans contredire nos
principes et sans manquer à la lutte des
classes écoutez le cri de notre pitié
nous pouvons dans le combat
révolutionnaire garder des entrailles du
maine nous ne sommes pas tenus pour
rester dans le socialisme de nous enfuir
or de l'humanité ce qu'il dit à propos
de l' affaire dreyfus c'est exactement
l'article râle la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme de
1948 que je reste pour ne pas connaître
tout être humain a droit au respect de
son égale dignité et donc le refus de la
raison d'état
ça nous conduit exactement est la guyane
ressemble à guantanamo et on peut
effectivement cité guantanamo cité aussi
l' usage de la torture qui a été
réinstaurée à propos à l'occasion de la
guerre contre l'irak par les états unis
comme des exemples de refus d'appliquer
les droits fondamentaux
alors que ce droit légal digne
et alors le mot n'existaient pas du
temps de jaurès mais juridiquement il
est devenu un droit indéniable
ce qui veut dire qu'un état ne peut pas
le bafouer même en cas de guerre
même en cas de terrorisme menaçant la
sûreté la survie de la nation
le seul problème c'est que ces beaux
principes il faut encore arriver à les
appliquer
plus la réputation de jaurès grandit
plus et haine contre lui s'exaspère pas
seulement à droite
mais même dans son camp où les jalousies
vient de renforcer les sectarismes comme
en témoigne la méchante querelle qui lui
est faite à propos d'une affaire privée
de 7 juillet 1901 ab soul est sur la
commune de villefranche d'albigeois ou
jaurès à sa maison sa fille madeleine
fait sa communion solennelle
le comité général du parti socialiste
est saisie d'une motion de certains
délégués qui demandent des explications
aux citoyens jaurès et au cas où ils ne
seraient pas satisfaisante de le relever
de toute délégation pouvant engager le
parti socialiste jaurès défunt dans la
petite république il écrit j'ai dit que
ma femme était chrétienne et pratiquante
j'ai pensé que je n'avais pas le droit
d'interdire à nos enfants de participer
au culte sous la direction de leur mère
et j'ai pensé aussi que mon devoir était
en les faisant élevé dans les
établissements laïques d'assurer la
liberté de leur esprit à ce devoir
je n'ai jamais manqué
[Musique]
si l'attaqué s'ils vivent c'est que le
contexte s'y prête
le grand débat sur les relations de la
république avec l'église catholique est
engagée depuis que jules ferry a
proclamé l'instruction gratuite laïque
et obligatoire au début des années 1880
les républicains tentent de limiter le
rôle de l'église dans l'éducation en ce
début de siècle
le gouvernement du bloc des gauches
interdit d'enseigner aux congrégations
qui dispensent aux enfants la foi
catholique et parfois la détestation de
la république
l'enjeu de ces affrontements c'est la
laïcité et cette idée elle vient d'assez
loin
alors si vous me permettez une seconde
mais c'est important pour comprendre
notre modernité dans le fond les
révolutions échouent la première et puis
on revient à la contre-révolution à l'
empire et donc on en fait une deuxième
10 848 échec
autour du petit napoléon ce qu'ils ont
vécu cet échec se disent mais pourquoi
nous n'arrivons pas à faire la
révolution en france et d'autres pays
qu'ont réussi les états unis
l'angleterre etc
que se passe-t-il et là ils font une
analyse et en particulier de gars qui
n'est dans son grand livre la révolution
qui va marquer toute une génération
jules ferry et bien entendu jaurès se
dit parce qu'on a commis une erreur on a
cru que la révolution elles étaient soit
matérielle dans les intérêts je vais
remplacer la noblesse par la bourgeoisie
soit purement politique c'est le cas là
en fait une révolution elle doit avoir
lieu dans les consciences dans les
esprits si on veut changer une société
il faut changer l'ordre des valeurs
l'ordre des représentations parce que
l'être humain est commandée par son
esprit c'est pour ça qu'ils vont faire
de l'école la priorité de
l'établissement la troisième république
et que ça va marcher parce qu'ils se
disent qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a
voulu la révolution matériel et puis on
a laissé à l'église toujours alliée avec
la contre-révolution le monopole des
esprits et on n'a pas pensé qu'il
fallait
à côté se forger une idéologie
républicaine et la faire partager au
plus grand nombre
c'est pour ça que l'école va être conçue
d'ailleurs comme devant transmettre ses
valeurs
jaurès a écrit un grand texte qui a été
publié après
sur la question religieuse et le
socialisme me reprend tout de cette
analyse elie la révolution elle doit
avoir lieu dans les esprits et elle doit
commencer par l'instruction publique
si nous voulons la justice et bien il
faut d'abord éduquer le peuple a aimé sa
propre liberté et être capable de la
construire
il est dans ce mouvement là qui est un
mouvement profondément dans le fond
spiritualiste et pas du tout le
mouvement marxiste qui lui disaient nous
allons changer l'organisation des forces
productives et ça va entraîner le
changement dans les consciences il deale
inverse il dit faut d'abord s'attaquer à
l'éducation des consciences pour un jour
pouvoir faire le changement dans
l'organisation économique
[Musique]
en 1905 la loi de séparation des églises
et de l'état
porté par l'habileté d'aristide briand
est adopté par le parlement dans un
climat de grande tension
réélu député en 1902 jaurès peut
déployer son éloquence et sa force de
persuasion au service de cette grande
cause
la seule façon de permettre à l'inde est
rejoint à l'autre d'être protestants au
troisième d'être musulman quatrième
d'être catholique c'est précisément la
laïcité parce qu'elle va faire coexister
toutes ces libertés entre elles de façon
pacifique ça n'avait pas été le cas
précédemment
la laïcité c'est d'abord une attitude
intellectuelle que l'on a vis-à-vis de
soi-même dogmatique laïque ne l'est
jamais parce que le laïque sous la forme
du dialogue lors même qu'il va se forger
une conviction va avoir à l'égard de sa
conviction une certaine distance et une
certaine interrogation il est celui qui
ne prétend jamais posséder la vérité
c'est la plus grande arme démocratique
ce qui fait sombrer les démocraties
c'est qu'il y a des gens qui un moment
pense posséder tout seul la vérité
donc l'état et on a besoin de lui c'est
ce qui va vous permettre de forger votre
propre liberté
c'est la plus grande difficulté michel
avait vu d'ailleurs de l'éducation et
nous l'avons encore devant nous d'une
éducation républicaine c'est qu'il faut
éduquer à la liberté on ne peut pas y
contraindre on ne peut pas les forcer
s'il n'y a pas ça c'est tout le
l'organisation politique de la
république qui s'effondre parce qu'elles
reposent toujours sur la liberté de
chacun
ces combats flamboyant de la maturité de
jaurès l'install comme l'un des plus
grands orateurs de son temps à la
tribune de la chambre autant que dans
les préaux et dans les meetings de plein
air ce néo look ans porté par une voix
sonore se nourrit de celle des anciens
grecs et latins
elle s'organise avec une ampleur qui
devant les auditoires populaire c'est
n'être jamais condescendante qui rejette
la démagogie et ne renonce jamais à
viser haut au prestige de l'orateur
jaurès ne cesse jamais de joindre celui
du journaliste ces articles
innombrables sont le fruit d'un labeur
qui nous paraît rétrospectivement
gigantesque pédagogie démocratique ne va
pas pour lui sans l'écriture qui la
porte
en 1904 je reste parviennent à
concrétiser un rêve celui d'un quotidien
qui dirige personnellement et où les
diverses familles du socialisme français
se trouveront généreusement accueillis
ainsi naît l'humanité tous les courants
politiques et biologiques ont leur
journal et lui il a besoin de son
journal pour mener ces combats pour
fédérer les socialistes pour une part
pour faire le lien avec le dans une
deuxième phase avec le mouvement
syndical puisque au début on appelle
l'humanité le journal des agrégés dédie
cet agrégé et peu à peu il se rend
compte que il faut discuter avec le
courant syndicales dont la cgt qui n'est
évidemment pas celle d'aujourd'hui il
ouvre le journal
à la cgt comment s'est organisée à
l'origine cette relation entre le monde
des intellectuels c'est un mot nouveau
fonds employés depuis l' affaire dreyfus
et d'autre part tous les militants du
mouvement ouvrier est ce que le journal
a représenté cette synthèse l'aï si oui
comment les ouvriers à qui devait il
devait s'adresser au début bon ne lisait
pas trop dit préférer les grands
journaux populaires
oui et s'occupe pour une part se
comprend et donc ils ont fait tous
effort d'écriture et ils ont fait
efforts d'élargissement
mais le fait qu'on l'ait appelé le
journal des agrégés à l'époque
et quand même quelque chose
d'extrêmement ball comment jaurès a
réussi à lancer un journal ça coûtait
déjà de l'argent comment est-ce que ça
s'est passé comment est il assuré
s'il est parvenu l'indépendance de son
journal de l'humanité par rapport à ce
qu à d'autres époques ont appelé les
puissances d'argent
il a dit dès son premier éditorial qu'
il y avait une
répartition des parts de manière égale
entre celles et ceux qui travaillaient
au journal qui le font des avec lui le
son conseil d'administration et d'un
côté il y avait effectivement les parcs
appartenait c'est très moderne ce qui
collaborait au journal il y avait
d'autres par des apports extérieurs prix
ne se vend pas aux puissances d'argent
loin de là mais il il est obligé de
faire des prêts et d'aller chercher de
l'argent à l'extérieur sans quoi il ne
peut pas tenir la droite en parle des
rothschild oui c'était vrai je pense je
pense qu'il a fait un voyage en
allemagne et il a il l'a trouvée à la
faveur de son combat au moment de l'
affaire dreyfus il a trouvé des gens qui
parce qu'il avait mené ce combat on dit
que ça valait le coup de soutenir cet
homme
le combat de cet homme et de ce journal
écrire librement comporte des dangers en
décembre 1904 paul déroulède chantre du
nationalisme outrancier jette ce cri de
haine à jaurès à propos d'un simple
entrefilet paru dans son journal
je vous tiens monsieur pour le plus
odieux pervertissent heures de
conscience qui jamais fait en france
le jeu de l'étranger jaurès à bout de
patience lui envoie ces témoins ses
camarades trouve absurde qu ils se
battent en duel et prenne un tel risque
j'ai pris le temps de la réflexion je ne
pouvais plus depuis quelques temps je
les sens tout cela près à m'insulter
dans ma femme ou dans ma fille je reçois
des lettres d'ordures je sens grimper
les limaces je me sens couvrir de
crachats je veux arrêter cela par un
geste ridicule mais nécessaire je ne
veux pas qu'on se croit tout permis
qu'on me mette dans la rue le bonnet
d'âne
[Musique]
le procès-verbal informe que deux balles
ont été échangés sans résultat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais se réjouit de la naissance en
1905 du parti socialiste unifié section
française de l'internationale ouvrière
sfio
à ses yeux l'unité des socialistes est
un but autant qu'un moyen
c'est le message d'ailleurs qu'il va
porter juillet à octobre 1911 en
amérique latine au brésil en uruguay et
en argentine ne s'agit pas seulement de
s'assurer des cachets généreux destiné à
renflouer l'humanité s'adressant en
français à de vastes auditoires jaurès
peut mesurer que sa notoriété et son
prestige sont devenus universels et qui
sont à même de servir le rayonnement de
la france autant que la solidarité
internationale du mouvement ouvrier
il fait trois grandes conférences qui
sont très très suivie sur des sujets de
fond et on se rend compte quand on les
lit aujourd'hui c'est d'une modernité
incroyable
il parlait de la question de
l'immigration déjà à cette époque qu'est
ce qu'il en dise m et aux bras il dit
des choses que dit aujourd'hui le
mouvement progressiste c'est à dire que
l'immigration telle qu'elle est
organisée aujourd'hui par les employeurs
certains disent le patronat vise bien
souvent à peser sur les salaires
ouvriers ou prolétaires qu'il disait à
l'époque du pays dans lequel ils
arrivent 12 ans risques de xénophobie
parmi ceux-là ils posaient c'est qu'il
posait ses questions il appelait lui à
l'unité à l'alliance en dix ans les
employer le mot de somme pour les ter
son frère etc
je crois que dans certains textes de de
jaurès sur la notion d'humanité qui
reste à construire une sorte de
peut-être de prémonition à l'époque lui
imagine que cette communauté va se
constituer à partir partir de l'union
des travailleurs les droits sociaux et
droits sociaux alors l'hydra sociaux
c'est une histoire étrange parce que en
fait il avait en partie raison jaurès
en quoi le traité de versailles va
instituer l'organisation internationale
du travail gros international et le
bureau international du travail
c'est la première organisation
internationale et elle est très
ambitieuse puisque le texte du traité de
versailles pose un certain nombre de
principes
avec un principe numéro un qui mérite
d'être appelé de temps en temps le
travail n'est pas une marchandise
donc c'était bien parti et finalement il
a quand même eu tort
en quoi parce qu'à l'heure actuelle les
droits sociaux non ne sont pas en tête
du mouvement d'internationalisation
c'est le contraire ce qui a pris le pain
c'est l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
elle a été créée beaucoup plus tard
c'est une des dernières à avoir été
créée en 1994 mais elle a tout de suite
été créé avec un système juridictionnel
qui permettent de juger
les états qui ne respectent pas les
principes du commerce la liberté du
commerce qui autorise des sanctions donc
on a un système qui est clairement
supranationale alors que l'oit et n'a
pas de juridiction pour faire appliquer
ces principes
l'internationalisation des travailleurs
s'est fait doubler par celle des
multinationales des entreprises
multinationales sont maintenant
extrêmement puissante plus puissante que
les syndicats plus puissante aussi que
certains étant donc ça c'est ce qui
n'était pas prévu
si l'humanité est accueillant à tous les
socialistes c'est que jaurès est
décidément obsédé par cette unité de son
parti seulement deux tendances
s'opposent deux catégories du militant
de famille d'esprit la réforme ou la
révolution
jules guesde l'autre leader majeur est
un marxiste efficace et sommaires qui
refusent de gladio l'isthme dans les
réformes parce qu'à ses yeux toute
amélioration partielle du sort des
prolétaires risquerait d'affaiblir leur
énergie de révoltés et la chance d'un
grand soin où le capitalisme serait d'un
seul coup renversée il voit dans la
bourgeoisie un ennemi unis et
irréductible alors que jaurès qui
discerne en elle une puissance
anarchique et diffuse souhaite s'allier
avec sa frange réformiste en 1899 il a
d'ailleurs approuvé contre beaucoup de
ses amis
l'entrée d'un socialiste gouvernement
pour y soutenir des lois de progrès
social
il ya un jaurès contrarier voile alors
expliqué moussa jaurès veut faire
l'unité des socialistes qui sont
éparpillés en plein de familles mais au
moment où il fait ça il va concéder un
peu à la tendance dite guest-list
marxiste matérialiste donc il est là non
plus le pur intellectuelle jaurès non
plus jaurès lui même et jaurès le chef
de parti qui cherche à rassembler et
donc qu'il fait des compromis tout le
xxème siècle socialiste va être dominée
par ce compromis j'aurais siens dont on
peut considérer est en tout cas c'est ma
lecture aujourd'hui qu'il n'a pas
nécessairement fait du bien à la gauche
française et parce que nous sommes dans
le divorce des actes et des discours
et si à une interprétation si
matérialiste et anti individuel ici
étatiste et une telle domination de la
pensée marxiste sur la pensée française
jaurès par les avants du socialisme
français avant 1905
c'est précisément parce qu'il ya ce
moment où jaurès concède pour obtenir
l'unité du parti
un certain nombre d'éléments de doctrine
à jules guesde quelle est la conviction
jaurès à l'époque c'est qu'il a le temps
pour lui c'est le même optimiste que
celui de clemenceau c'est que sa
supériorité intellectuelle est telle que
ce moment tactique de 1905 va être
dépassé par l'histoire et c'est vrai
qu'il commençait à le dépasser mais il a
été assassiné et donc d'une certaine
façon ce processus s'interrompt et donc
quand on étudie jaurès il est à la fois
un formidable ressource positive et
actuel pour penser des éléments comme la
morale laïque l'individualisme
républicain la dimension spirituelle
d'une vie en société et d'un lien social
évidemment aussi la justice mais il doit
nous faire réfléchir aussi sur le prix
des compromis en politique car d'une
certaine façon ce très grand
intellectuel qui à un moment pour des
raisons je dirais de contingences
historiques fait l'unité des socialistes
fait payer paye lui même très cher
ce compromis la rupture avec
coût de ses amis de la revue socialiste
à l'époque il ya beaucoup de socialistes
français issus de cette tradition qu'on
évoquait tout leur qui vont prendre
leurs distances avec jaurès à ce moment
là et quand on lit l'histoire du
socialisme
on voit que ce divorce entre deux
théories socialistes et deux attitudes
dont jaurès effet essaye de faire la
synthèse
on va les retrouver à tout moment de
l'histoire de la gauche ce qui explique
que le parti socialiste qui a eu parfois
des pratiques opportuniste au pouvoir a
toujours tenu des discours très marxiste
de lutte des classes est donc un écart
formidable dans nos concitoyens ont
d'ailleurs parfois souffert entre le
discours et les pratiques
[Musique]
ces querelles rebondissent lors de tous
les congrès de l'internationale
socialiste
amsterdam à bruxelles as tu de garde à
londres et les chocs de personnes se
mêlent aux controverses doctrinale
les deux familles du socialisme celle
qui tient pour l'absolu de la révolution
est celle qui sent en abandonner leurs
rêves acceptent des concessions au réel
et le pas à pas du progrès social
continue longtemps d'être antagonistes
jaurès quelques concessions qu'il ait dû
faire ou tenants du tout ou rien ne
renonce pas un syncrétisme au service de
ce qu'il appelle le beau soleil de
l'unité
[Musique]
merci vous prolongez jaurès salines son
influence et que vous arrivez à lénine
j'avais l'impression d'une continuité
d'une rupture ils sont à l'international
tous les deux mais les need n'est pas
d'accord avec jaurès dayori dit il dit
aux délégués socialistes français les
tendances des 10 et délégués socialistes
français méfiez vous de cette eau mais
quels arguments emploi t-il il n'emploie
aucun argument politique ou idéologique
et le redis il est trop brillant
[Musique]
bien plus tard lorsqu en 1924 le
gouvernement du cartel des gauches fait
transférer les cendres de jaurès depuis
albi jusqu'au panthéon le rêve d'unité a
volé en éclats balayé par une guerre
mondiale et par la révolution
bolchévique
deux cortèges style accompagne jaurès
l'un communiste l'autre socialiste et
radical
les mineurs de carmaux sourd aux
querelles et fidèle à jaurès pouces
l'immense pavois roulant qui porte sa
dépouille
quand les socialistes disent que vous
avez fait capturer la mémoire de jeu
reste en effet un acte de saisie au
profit du parti communiste et qu'il
appartient autant aux socialistes
qu'est ce que vous dites au moment où il
le disait le parti communiste n'était
pas très j'aurais siens le parti
communiste il était plutôt dans une voie
de bol je vise à sion donc tous les
jeunes jaurès ringard tiennent l'un et
l'autre ont tordu un petit peu la
réalité moi ce que je souhaiterais ce
cas à la fois les socialistes soient
jaurésien et que les communistes aussi
heureux devient juriste le redevienne
ils le sont plus qu'ils ne l'ont été
jusque je disais depuis les années 75 76
je pense que les communes y sont sont
son j'aurais siens au sens de la
démarche au sens de la la manière de
penser la transformation sociale on
n'est plus aux grands soirs on est plus
à la dictature du prolétariat
[Musique]
à l'automne 2009 112 tandis que les
balkans s'enfièvre à nouveau et menaces
à court terme d'enflammer toute l'europe
le bureau de l'internationale socialiste
convoque à bâle un congrès
extraordinaire un seul point est à
l'ordre du jour la paix la paix a sauvé
dans la cathédrale jaurès prononce de
plus célèbre de ses discours
j'appelle les vivants pour qu'ils se
défendent contre le monstre qui apparaît
à l'horizon
je pleure sur les morts innombrables
couché là bas vers l'orient et dont la
puanteur arrivent jusqu'à nous comme un
remords je briserai les foudres de la
guerre qui menace dans les nuées
oui j'ai entendu cette parole
d'espérance
mais cela ne suffit pas à empêcher la
guerre il faudra toute l'action
concordantes du prolétariat mondial et
jaurès incite ses camarades a juré en se
séparant sauver la paix et la
civilisation
donc on continue d'évoquer en cas de
conflit imminent une grève générale et
internationales du prolétariat mais déjà
les observateurs les acteurs les plus
lucides discerne que de chaque côté du
rhin les traditions les tempéraments les
doctrines se dessine comme trop
divergentes pour que cette éventualité
soit probable
en france un projet de loi prévoit dans
la perspective de la guerre possible et
pour éviter à déficit des effectifs de
porter le service militaire de deux à
trois ans jaurès s'engage ou parlement
et dans le pays dans une campagne
méthodique contre les trois ans la loi
des trois ans copie dans son mécanisme
de casernes le militarisme allemand
notre projet est d'accroître la
puissance défensive de la france le
devoir est de développer les garanties
d'avenir qui conviennent à un grand
peuple par l'éducation de la jeunesse
par l'organisation des réserves par
l'armement du peuple sur place
le 25 mai 1913 le parti socialiste
organise une vaste manifestation contre
la loi au pré-saint-gervais jeu récit
parle devant près de cent mille
personnes et son discours est resté
fameux je demande à tous ceux qui
prennent au sérieux la vie qu'allez vous
faire de vos 20 ans on vous dit c'est le
refrain d'aujourd'hui aller à l'action
mais qu'est ce donc que l'action sans la
pensée c'est la brutalité et l'inertie
on vous dit écartez vous de ce parti de
la paix qui débite les courages et nous
nous disons qu'aujourd'hui l'affirmation
de la paix est le plus grand des combats
dans le même temps se déchaîne contre
lui des déferlement de haine dont on
peine aujourd'hui à prendre la mesure
on le traite de tambour major de la
capitulation d'agents du parti allemand
et de traître par essence et pas
seulement à l'extrême droite ou dans les
colonnes de l'action française
léon daudet appel sans détour a tué
jaurès
mais chez charles péguy lui même qui
bien loin des fraternités dreyfusarde de
jadis
tiens ce propos effrayant dès la
déclaration de guerre
première chose que nous ferons sera de
fusiller jaurès ne laisseront pas
derrière nous c'est traître pour nous
poignarder dans le dos
cerné par temps d'imprécations jean
jaurès écrit en juillet 1913
si j'ai eu parfois la tentation de
mesurer ma valeur propre et les services
quand une vie de dévouement et de combat
j'ai pu rendre à mon parti et à la
république
si j'avais la tentation de les mesurer à
la violence des haines permanente que
j'inspire alors je commettrais sans
doute le péché d'orgueil
[Musique]
monde
le meurtrier du 31 juillet 1914
raoul villain n'aura plus qu'à conclure
j'ai abattu le porte drapeau le grand
traître de l'époque de la loi de trois
ans à grande gueule qui couvrait tous
les appels de l'alsace-lorraine jeu les
punis
la fin de l'histoire de ce crime est
stupéfiante vilain demeure en prison
pendant toute la guerre et il est par la
protéger du risque militaire alors que
oui j'aurai ce fils unique est mort au
feu
[Musique]
l'assassin est jugé en mars 1919 dans
une atmosphère de patriotisme des
voiliers et il est acquitté par un jury
populaire
la veuve de jaurès chose inouïe et
condamné à régler les frais de justice
des manifestations spontanées ont lieu
anatole france écrit dans l'humanité un
verdict monstrueux proclame que cet
assassinat n'est pas un crime
travailleurs veillez ce verdict me met
hors la loi vous et tous ceux qui
défendent votre cause
ironie de l'histoire bil'in au terme du
pauvre vie d'errance meurt en 1936 au
début de la guerre civile d'espagne à
ibiza fusillé par les républiques sans
qu'on sache à coup sûr si ceux-ci la
bête identifier
[Musique]
faut-il donc faire de jean jaurès et de
ce qu'ils nous laissent un privilège de
la gauche ou bien plutôt un héritage
pour tous on aura peut-être le goût de
suivre léon blum qui plus que nulle
autre voulu s'en inspirer et lui être
fidèle et qui disait nous le gardons
pour nous et tout en le gardant nous le
remettons à la nation et à l'histoire
[Musique]
ah ah
la peau
[Musique]